good evening I'm Sarah Huckabee Sanders
we know being a mom to three young
children
I mean not to believe every story I hear
so forgive me for not believing much of
anything I heard tonight from President
Biden from out of control inflation and
violent crime remember violent crime
trending down inflation down six months
in a row
the dangerous border crisis and threat
from China remember that nothing has
substantively changed with border policy
from Trump to Biden the China thing is
sort of like an amorphous one
Biden and the Democrats have failed you
they know it and you know it nothing
really factual there